Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with the president and CEO of Media Matters,
Angelo Carusone.
We're going to talk about, well, many, many
different things.
Angelo, it's great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Likewise.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: So to start with.
There is a feeling that Fox News in particular
and maybe some other right wing media are
starting to set up a little bit of like an
eject button or an escape hatch where Donald
Trump not to be the Republican nominee.
In 2024, Fox News ran like a man on the street
segment where they had a bunch of people saying,
Oh, no, if it was up to me, it would be DeSantis,
who's the nominee.
They're not really against Trump, but it feels
as though they're setting up an escape hatch.
Is that your sense of what's going on?
Speaker 6: Yeah.
I think that's a really I like the way that
you put it because I a lot of people oftentimes
put it like they've turned on Trump, right.
Oh, that's that's a little extreme.
But the escape hatch is the right way to think
about it, which is that, you know, one of
the things that has happened and is that,
you know, in the past, Trump sort of captured
Fox News, his audience, and was able to really
leapfrog Fox News and speak directly to them.
And then the audience, you know, kind of forced
Fox to align.
That's how he captured I mean, he seized it.
Yeah.
He doesn't have the same tools available to
him.
There's opposing candidates like the scientists
that helped create some of that friction.
So what they're basically doing is hedging.
And I will just remind everyone that this
is a very similar posture that Fox News was
in and poor place in 2015.
You know, in 2013, they had the Fox News primary
where you would have candidates that would
get a ton of attention.
They would be the flavor of the two weeks
and they would shoot to the top.
And there was people criticizing Trump on
air, on network.
You know, there was factions within Fox that
had different people that they supported.
And I think that's starting to emerge right
now.
I also think, you know, they're trying to
they're hedging because it's not clear that
Trump is going to be able to replicate what
they did in 20 in 2016, and they kind of know
it.
So escape hatch is exactly the right way to.
Speaker 1: Put it to go back to 2015, 2016.
There was that early period where Fox was
very much not on the Trump train.
And as you say, ultimately they did acquiesce.
Is there anything about the back story of
the relationship between Trump and the Murdochs
that is relevant to how that went?
Or was that not a factor in your mind?
Speaker 6: It was not so much of a factor.
It was really about Roger Ailes.
The only thing that was relevant at the time
about the Murdochs is that Rupert Murdoch
has always wanted Fox to really have a president,
like not to just have an alliance with the
president.
You know, they were obviously aligned with
the Bush administration, but there was a they
were two different entities that sort of had
some synergy.
I mean, what Murdoch has always fantasized
about has been to really create a president
or, you know, a world leader, but really a
president.
And so what when Ailes started to put more
of the Fox News juice behind Trump, as things
started to seem to break in his favor, Murdoch
really saw that as an opportunity to create
something.
And that's where he sort of said, okay, I'm
all in now.
And then he cashed in on those favors as soon
as Trump got into office, right?
By doing some pretty outrageous things, trying
to get him to slow down the deal so that he
could come up with and maybe even buy CNN.
And, you know, it really that was the determining
factor.
But it wasn't until after it was pretty clear
that Trump could capture the nomination that
Murdoch said, okay, we can go all in now.
Speaker 1: Before the FBI search at Mar a
Lago, there was this stretch of time where
Trump was just gone from Fox News.
He was doing and still is doing interviews
where oftentimes he's just literally phoning
it in channels that nobody's heard of.
And, you know, it seemed as though maybe this
was a sign that his star is fading after the
search.
That was the entire the Sean HANNITY interview,
which, by the way, was a total, total disaster.
It didn't really do anything good for him.
But put that aside for a second.
Was there something to that absence from Fox
News in your mind?
Speaker 6: There was.
Now, they still talked about him 9 to 10,
15 times more than anybody else.
Yeah, but there was something to it.
Two things, actually.
One was that was the beginning of the January
six hearings.
And there was all of this information coming
out, testimony where, you know, there was
actually, you know, Fox News hosts were part
of it where they were actually texting and
talking.
So it complicated things a little bit.
And then the second thing and this is really
important is that the defamation lawsuit that
from Dominion, which is that voting machine
company that's suing Fox News for $1,000,000,000,
they had been arguing for almost seven, eight
months that the Murdochs would not be part
of it.
And just in the beginning of the summer, it
was that the courts ruled that actually the
Murdochs will be a part of this litigation.
And what that meant is that Fox executives
in the Murdochs were trying to demonstrate
that, oh, there's some distance between us
and Trump.
And there was a little bit of back and forth
over that summer as they started to calibrate
their legal strategy.
So I think it was really those two things
coming together, which is let's keep them
at arm's length because every time he appears
on our network, he's either it's either going
to create a new round of stories about our
hosts from January six, or it's going to complicate
the back end stuff that we're dealing with
with this massive billion dollar lawsuit.
Speaker 1: So I want to get off FOX after
one more question and get on to some other
right wing media outlets.
But at this point, do you have a sense of
who's more powerful within the Republican
base in terms of Trump or Fox News, in the
sense of if Trump says, I'm running and Fox
did decide we actually want to prevent Trump
from being the nominee, who is the power right
now?
Speaker 6: Tucker.
Speaker 1: Tucker.
Okay.
Speaker 6: Specifically, Tucker is just Tucker.
And so the rest of Fox would have to would
break for Trump at this point.
Fox would be able to capture Trump would be
able to hijack the Fox audience.
And we're seeing that play out a little bit
right now with the attacks on Pelosi, because
it has been, you know, Fox initially treated
like a traditional crime story and then after
sort of the Trump part of the ecosystem was
weaving conspiracies, all of a sudden Fox
News sort of broke and went with the conspiracy
direction.
So there's lots of indicators like that.
So if Fox was against Trump, Trump would win
that fight.
But if Tucker is, then Trump is in trouble
because Tucker really has replaced Limbaugh
as sort of like the what he used to describe
as the titular head of the Republican Party.
Tucker has really filled that space.
So Trump v fox.
Trump Trump v Tucker.
Speaker 1: Tucker what do you make of recently
even Newsmax?
So the way I put some of these on a spectrum
is you've got Fox, which is on the right,
and then you've got Newsmax, which is crazier
than Fox, and then you've got Oann, which
is crazier than Newsmax that I sort of have
them like that.
And you can tell me whether you agree or disagree.
Newsmax recently is not even taking all of
Donald Trump's rallies.
They still take most of them, but not all
of them.
Does that mean that even within the even crazier
wing, maybe Trump's star is fading?
Speaker 6: A little bit.
And it's also you know, it's a little complicated,
too, because they are some other entities
went out there and really cornered that market
of the rallies live.
So, you know, Trump's own lawyer hosts the
right side broadcasting.
Right.
I mean, when they're so yeah, I mean, they
have an inside track.
Fox News actually has an entire channel on
their Fox Nation app that they will give away
free trials for.
So they use the Trump rallies to get more
people to sign up.
The entire section is devoted to just Trump's
rallies, so they kind of others got into the
space to try to commercialize it.
So I think there's a financial like cornering
the market factor.
But I look at the metrics, you know, they
see that, you know, the rallies don't have
the same juice and star power that they did
in the past.
And for Newsmax, which has slightly thinner
margins, it doesn't get them the same bang
for the buck.
And also every time he says something about
the election, they have to worry about their
channels and getting zapped.
And so for them, it's just it's just not worth
it.
Speaker 1: So you talked a little bit about
the Trump versus someone else primary in terms
of Tucker and the power dynamics there.
But if we zoom out a little and even like
separate it maybe from from from Fox News,
how do you believe right wing media more generally
will handle if it's Trump?
DeSantis Because I don't think DeSantis can
be written off as a RINO in the same way that
they do with like Mitt Romney, for example.
So what do you think they're going to come
up with for covering such a primary?
Speaker 6: It's going to be really hard.
There's two complicating factor.
There's two big considerations.
One is that DeSantis has a pretty potent piece
of like kryptonite that he started to deploy,
which is vaccines.
And it started over the summer.
And he started to basically, you know, he's
been apologizing for saying that he he was
misled.
He should have never promoted the vaccines
is probably the only wedge where he can really
successfully outflank Trump to the right and
have credibility with the right wing media.
And that's what it's about.
It's about sort of hijacking the right wing,
outflanking Trump when it comes to some of
these right wing personalities to say, look
at the Santos, you know, he's willing to accept
the fact that he should have and he's been
anti-vax and he's anti state control and we're
free, you know, liberty and you know, he did
it a little bit over the summer and it worked.
It changed the way right wing media talked
about them.
That's when Alex Jones started to really hit
Donald Trump was on the vaccine stuff.
And then you could look at a bunch of these
right wing media hosts that were saying, Oh,
Trump's going to have to grapple with this
at some point.
I mean, why won't he just say he was lied
to?
Why won't he apologize about this?
He's so stubborn.
And dissent has started to, you know, basically
deploy it as a trial balloon, did it for about
six weeks and he walked it back.
So I think one is how heavily he leans into
that and how Trump navigates that is a weakness
because it's Trump's base is not with Trump
on this, and that is this weird tension where
he's out of step with them.
And so that's one.
And I think that will affect the way the media
lines up, because it will give them cover.
To then criticize Trump in a way that doesn't
get them blowback from their own audiences
is to get him on that terrain.
So that's that's one part.
And then the other part is, is actually a
knock against a is that dissent is is no fun.
So the truth is, nobody really likes him,
right?
That's what everyone's hedging on.
And I'm not trying to be mean or glib about.
It's the truth.
He really is no fun.
Even his closest allies acknowledge that he's
genuinely no fun.
He's aloof, he's not charismatic.
He's.
And if you're in the media, you need to think
about the product and what's the sustaining
and staying power.
And that's the challenge with DeSantis, is
that I think from the media perspective, they're
all aware of the fact that DeSantis doesn't
have the same sort of regenerative power in
terms of media consumption in the way that
that Trump does.
So it's this weird thing, but I do think the
vaccine piece is going to really be challenging
and Trump is going to take a lot of flak for
that from the right wing media.
And if they want to jump, that's going to
be their launchpad.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you about.
What is the timing of the 2024 primary getting
going?
Because some part of me thinks it gets going
on November 9th, quite frankly.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I think you're right.
I have always been pointing to the fact that
there's no way that Trump would announce a
candidacy until his airplane was ready.
And it was supposed to be ready back in July.
But of course, because of all the supply chain
issues, pieces of it weren't complete and
the timeline got radically disrupted.
It is now officially finished.
There's no way that he would run for president
without his plane.
It's too and it's too much of an important
part of the staging.
Right.
And so it's just it was an obvious to me.
It just felt very obvious that he couldn't
be a candidate without his plane.
It doesn't work.
And and so that's to me, if this plane wasn't
ready, I would say we have to wait.
But because his plane is now ready, I agree
with you.
I think it's going to start almost immediately
after November 9th.
And that ties into what's happening now, because
a lot of what's happening on the ground, the
infrastructure at the state level, a lot of
the organizations, the the cluster of groups
that are going to get power or potentially
get power if the election goes in their favor.
This is all part of the Trump ecosystem that
has been building this groundwork.
So it's going to almost be at the apex and
a more and a lot of momentum for him to make
a quick jump.
And he's also seen to the extent that they're
going to challenge any elections, he is really
the face of that strategy and approach.
So I think you're right, it's going to start
very, very, very early.
Speaker 1: And it sounds like from the language
you're using, you have no doubt whatsoever
that Trump is running.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
I think he's going to run for sure.
I do.
I don't think there's any reason to stop him
from running.
And he is fueled in large part by spite and
revenge.
And every measurable indicator still shows
that he could succeed in the primary.
His assessment of DeSantis is that he is too
miserable of a person to successfully hire
to replace him as the head of the party.
And DeSantis, I think, is going to.
I think he's a little hesitant to get too
bloodied up by Trump because it can be a messy
battle.
So there is a little bit of a delicate balancing
act there.
But yeah, I do.
I think for a lot of reasons, there's no there's
no doubt that he will in my mind that he will
run unless there's some major intervening
circumstance.
Speaker 1: This is really the last thing,
and then I'll let you go.
It seems very clear that there's a lot of
people in right wing media right now and even
some of the candidates starting to prepare
for if we lose, it was rigged.
But we also know that that caused significant
legal problems for a lot of media when they
did it with 2020.
What do you expect on November 9th, 10th or
11th, as far as that story goes?
Speaker 6: Yeah.
I think the one thing that I would just point
out and I'm glad you asked this, is that because
it demonstrated to be a challenge, they've
adapted.
And the way that they adapted was by building
an infrastructure of these groups and entities
that they'll be able to cite and reference,
and they're disposable.
Speaker 1: So you could so they can say, this
group makes this claim and they filed this
lawsuit.
Speaker 6: Exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
And so they really and there's a lot of synergies,
about 14 of them in operation right now.
They're promoting all these apps that help
collect this information.
Most of them are disposable.
They're not infrastructure.
They're not designed to have staying power.
They're shells.
And that was a way that and they've done little
ones at the major states.
There's one in Pennsylvania, there's one in
Arizona.
They're all tied into right wing media.
They get a lot of attention and a lot of press,
a lot of engagement, a lot of audience traction.
They've been pumping pumping them up now for
about about ten months.
And so that's the workaround, is that they've
found a way to essentially create a shield
so that the media operations can engage in
the same kinds of attacks.
But now they have this layer of cover.
They'll never get sued for.
Citing a third party organization or third
party organization can get sued, but they
won't.
That was Fox's problem.
You know, in in 2020, 26, 2020 is that they
were just saying these things, that they were
getting texted, you know, they were the source.
And now they've really found a way to to to
create that.
And I think that is the one thing that I don't
think people broadly have a full handle on
is that they've built the infrastructure to
actually do what they did in 2020, but at
scale, in a much more professional way and
in a much more scale and much more volume.
Speaker 1: Yeah, slick and scary at the same
time, I guess I would say we've been speaking
with the president and CEO of Media Matters,
Angelo Carusone.
Always great to talk to you and appreciate
your insights.
Speaker 6: Thanks for having me